so now that we understand how services
work let's review how Android determines
your apps priority app priority is
divided into three general buckets
critical high and low within each bucket
the apps are prioritized in a queue with
the app that's been at the lowest
priority for the longest the first to be
executed critical apps are those that
are active they're in the foreground
interacting with users that includes
activities in the foreground and apps
running foreground services high
priority apps include any visible
activities and any application with a
running service while less impactful
than killing a foreground app destroying
visible activities or canceling services
running tasks like background updates
it's still going to be noticeable to
users so the system will only kill them
in an extreme resource crunch apps in
the background though they're the red
shirted instance of the app priority
landing party any background app will be
killed as needed in a last scene first
killed order in order to help support
the higher priority apps I like to think
of this as the three laws of Android
resource management law one Android will
keep all apps that interact with the
user running smoothly Android will keep
all apps with visible activities or
running services running unless doing so
violates the first law and third Android
will keep all apps in the background
running unless this violates the first
or second laws so with all of that in
mind consider these four apps what do
you think is the priority order of each
of these apps according to the system